you said your mom this is actually
adorable you said your mom ordered a
song from heaven oh god yeah oh man so I
have a saw my record called she'd say
and basically it's been ten years since
I lost my mom and I walked into my house
this year and my wife goes oh I got you
a phone call with a medium today at 1:00
p.m. and I was like okay I feel like I'm
supposed to pretend like I'm against
that I'm like I'm kind of into that you
know oh I make the call and the guy
immediately goes oh yeah your mom's here
Cathy right I'm like why okay I keep
going and Google you could have googled
and he goes she she really wants you
she's like very adamant she needs you to
write a song from her to your daughter
about everything she would say to her if
she was there but she gave you there to
say it
are you brutal trying to me I was rough
so I'm like oh my god that's such a good
idea
and I'm like write the song and my mom
loved Graceland by Paul Simon yeah so I
get this phone call where she orders the
song apparently I write the song and
then I get in the car and turn the radio
and on the radio I was like ladysmith
black mambazo
which is the group that he went to make
Graceland with it's there nine males
from South Africa they're like they're
gonna be in Los Angeles on Friday and
I'm like sitting in the car like so we
chased them down and they came in to the
studio and they surrounded me and
they're singing in Zulu I miss my mom
and that's what she'd say in Zulu okay
we like wrote this song for my little
girl and at the end you can hear my
little girl's voice say like grandma
Kathy oh no it was a lot it's like
you're just trying to kill me yeah
what's nuts is now that insane
experience for me a lot of people have
heard it in different parts of their
lives and been like oh that's my grandma
or that's my mother that I lost you know
that is incredible cuz at first were you
very skeptic you were like okay my mom a
little bit skeptical but she that idea
is very her so yeah what a minute
I think that I think if you've lost
anyone I'm pretty sure they see
everything hey huh honestly and I also
think that they can just like order
songs so
those other I will not stop talking
until you subscribe to my youtube
channel that's right and I could talk a
lot seriously not gonna stop yep still
here not going anywhere I see you don't
walk away from this